also 3 vorn habe ich zumindest noch nie
gesehen in dieser farbe das geht
eigentlich ganz neues aus man muss halt
auch sagen jetzt passt nicht ganz
perfekt runter gefallen und herzlich
willkommen bei einem 98 vorfeld bei
einem neuen video
ja weil ich weiß natürlich euch geht es
gut mir auch zu mir das gestern kein
video kam leider brauchte ich einen tag
pause aber ihr wisst ja auf diesem kanal
gibt es jeden tag und 19 uhr ein neues
video deswegen und wenn es noch nicht
gemacht frau hier den kanal aktiviert
die werke weil heute machen wir weiter
mit einem video was ist vor peru das
schon ganz schön lange her ich will mal
sagen verfasst um jahr habe ich das
schon mal gemacht da habt ihr bei mir
jetzt zehn kostenlose produkte gesehen
die habe ich euch getestet und ich habe
gesehen dass videos eigentlich ganz gut
angekommen weil da habe ich mich bei dem
ein oder anderen produkt nicht wirklich
informiert deswegen habe ich gedacht ich
mach das einfach noch mal und diesmal
besser
das heißt heute gibt es wieder ein paar
davon ich kann mich aber auch sagen ich
habe insgesamt 30 kostenlose rich
artikel bestellt wovon jetzt schon zehn
da sind heute machen wir zehn nächste
woche kommt er nochmal zehn danach die
woche noch mal zehn alles kostenlos man
muss zu den versand bezahlen der dann
doch ganz schön feist aber es wird
bestimmt interessant deswegen würde ich
sagen wie lange schlange und das geht
natürlich schon super geil aus hier kann
man hier sind überall chinesische
solchen also ich glaub das meiste von
diesem kostenlosen dinge kommen heute
wirklich aus china oder wir legen wir
hier mal alle zuleitungen und haushalte
insgesamt für das ausgegeben das war
ganz schön teuer obwohl es ging
eigentlich als ich würde sagen man kann
so ein artikel mit zwei bis drei euro
versand rechnung weil die halt nicht
groß sind fast 60 euro gekostet für 30
sachen insgesamt an sich nicht unbedingt
kostenlos ja okay wir fangen mit dem
ersten an ich blende euch dann auch hier
mal den artikel 1 und ich kann euch
versprechen da sind wirklich einige
nützliche gadgets dabei und sachen die
wirklich geil sind wir jetzt hier im
ersten paar gute sachen haben weiß ich
nicht was das sind also dann da wird es
schon erstmal richtig gut los haben wir
besondere band anscheinend hatte machen
na ja also ich glaube da kann man sagen
da hat sich jetzt der versand nicht
gelohnt
das passt ja auch gar nicht es was hast
du denn fitness band da kannst du nicht
an ach komm mal hier kannst du die ganze
zeit einstellen
genau jetzt wieder aus das ist glaube
ich einfach nur nicht und du kannst halt
die uhrzeit einstellen kommerz ist zum
beispiel 41 das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
einfach die uhrzeit an
also es geht halt irgendwie mal aus also
ich finde es cool dass man so was gerade
ist bekommen kann fasst gerade ist aber
eigentlich kannst es direkt in mülfort
weil also ich hab mich jetzt mal kurz
informiert das ist wohl wirklich zum
sport machen aber halt einfach nur noch
an rom anhalt die uhrzeit sind also hier
kann das jetzt nicht aber in einem
gratis so wir kommen dann zum nächsten
produkt was niemals nächsten das hier
ich habe keine ahnung ich habe nur ganz
leicht rein geschaut weil ich die sachen
ja alle sortieren muss weil ich so viele
verschiedene sachen bestellt habe hier
habe ich mich gefragt okay was wir das
sein weil ich habe keine ahnung
okay wir haben hier eine einer losen für
iphone 7 habe ich bestellt iphone 7 +
müsste das seien also ich hab einfach 7
+ angeben wenn ich mir sicher und das
ist wohl sonne
wie sagt man nie sonstiger ist das
eigentlich der mann über das iphone
reden kann und das problem jetzt mal aus
okay mein armes tennis vorbei wer hat
bitte ein iphone in dieser farbe gibt's
ja gar nicht wieso ist julien was helfen
uns haben wir ein problem er kann sich
damit aus illegal handys repariert das
passiere nicht mal richtig drauf
genommen
ja es kommt aus vielleicht sind in china
liege fälschen iphones andere größe das
passt nicht ganz gut jetzt einfach
runter und dann
wenn ich mal gespannt was jetzt hier in
der seite was ja es geht drei saisonen
iphone habe ich zumindest noch nie
gesehen in dieser farbe es sieht
eigentlich ganz nice aus
man muss halt auch sagen es passt nicht
ganz perfekt ich würde eigentlich das
ist jetzt trotzdem einfach mal dran rote
hülle guter instagram account alex wie
würde ich auf jeden fall mal abschicken
und folgen und keine ahnung wenn jetzt
jemand mal sagt er ich habe ja mal ein
rotes iphone bestellt euch das ist halt
gratis
also ich finde dass auf jeden fall ein
leichtes ding was man sich mal so eben
bestellen kann kostet fast nichts
zwei haben wir schon mal weiter mit
diesem mir ich hab keine angst das habe
ich mir extra bestellt und zwar das sind
wirklich die ganzen socken
die müssen jetzt nur noch raus kommen
ich habe mir letztes jahr für dieses
video viele sorten gestellt die kann man
dort kostenlos erwerben und zwar steht
da drauf entweder shut up oder [ __ ] it
steht halt drauf und jetzt habe ich die
anderen bestellt mit ob gut oder also
und das sind socken die trage ich sehr
oft stammend hat sagt ein fuß also die
kann man auf jeden fall wenn man so ein
instagram influenza wie ich es mit den
vielen sachen kombinieren deine socken
also deswegen habe ich ja noch mal
bestellt ist jetzt zwar nichts krasses
aber ja wo kriegt man schon socken fast
kostenlos bevor ich mich jetzt weiter
über die sachen freue hier bin ich jetzt
auch mal gespannt
das könnten wir euch ja immer hier ein
was das für gegenstand ist und zwar sind
dass sie wohl zum grillen putzer also
die haben halt die aufgabe eine brille
zu putzen ihr kennt haben irgendwie
haben eine sonde wir haben jetzt gerade
eine sonnenbrille sehr dreckig und
normalerweise macht man das ja dann so
höhe und damit t shirt diese länger
sollen heute viel besser reich kann man
hier und man putzt sogar gleichzeitig
von beiden seiten das heißt wir stehen
jetzt mal hier rüber
ja also die brille ist wirklich dreckig
weiß nicht ob man das so gut auf der
kamera sieht
[Musik]
grundwasser also da ist schon ein
unterschied geht wollte das recht ja ich
mache auch mal kurzzeitig habe jetzt
bisschen was drauf gemacht mir zu sagen
da sieht man unterschiede oder komplett
nicht ganz in die ecken würde ja das
findet also ein gewisses scheiße muss
man ganz klar sagen ohne wasser hat es
nicht wirklich was gebracht ein bisschen
vielleicht mit wasser auch nicht
deswegen ist das hier eine komplette
drecks erfindung die kein mensch braucht
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt weiß was es ist weißt du nicht
zu papa bestimme ich habe das ist jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht für diesen teil
davon extra videos machen ich habe bei
steffers trail gefunden also wirklich
richtig pfeffer spray ihr hört sich
jetzt auch richtig was drin das ist das
erste was dazu angekommen ist die
anderen fehlen auch deswegen ging rasend
schnell zur seite
dazu wird es bald ein video geben ob das
funktioniert lässt man einfach kannst du
dich dann als versuchskaninchen der
opfer genau elia ok deswegen macht man
mal schnell weiter weißt was ich auch
gestellt habt so das ist dann richtig
deutsches gadget glas der sohn mütze auf
und kann es darunter sind dann so leds
die camp sowieso an die mütze
weißt du soviel nachts aber ich glaube
das hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun aber
ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
ich weiß was es ist genau da habe ich
mich nämlich sehr darauf gefreut
das ist für den wasserhahn hier bei uns
in der küche und zwar wird das wasser
dann glaube leuchtet was da rauskommt
und das muss man halt da dran schrauben
wollen wir noch nicht
[Musik]
also ich frage mich wer sowas braucht
aber eigentlich geil das problem ist der
wasserhahn von bad also das passt da
nicht dran weil er zu groß ist ich weiß
nicht das wäre natürlich am besten wenn
man das so dran stecken kann oder dran
dreht man hier kann man das ja
eigentlich drehen nur ich frag mich
jetzt wie das funktioniert aber ich muss
sagen es geht also das überzeugt mich
kauft gerne geiles wie sagt man das
match okay wir machen weiter ich glaube
wir sind jetzt bei normalen sechs oder
sieben keine ahnung und das hier ist
also ich habe keine ahnung ich muss
wirklich sagen das ist gar nicht mal so
leicht da irgendwelche kostenlosen
sachen zu finden ich habe echt ein zwei
stunden gesucht bis ich so viele
zusammen hatte was das jetzt hier ist
ich habe einer ich hab keine ahnung
leute ich weiß was ist das ist fürs auto
klebt man vorne dran dann kann man
nämlich sein handy hier dran
weylandt war funktioniert super toll
also ich kann jetzt schon sagen hier ist
ein kleiner magnet drin ist allerdings
viel zu spaßig lassen aber siehst ja das
ist doch dann so unnötige ressourcen
verschwendung sind blöd sind hier zu
produzieren denn nicht mehr anhalten
handy halten kann also hierzu muss ich
leider sagen kompletter scheiß leute wir
mal ganz schön ins auto und testen ob
das wirklich nicht funktioniert weil ich
sehe es nicht ein dass ich also mit
dieser seite geht schon mal nicht ich
heiße es jetzt warten wir noch so einen
kleber element lieber wenn man hier
gönnt ihm schlange hat licht element
wieder angemacht so kennt man jetzt hier
dran
und jetzt zeige ich euch die absolute
stärke von ruhig es geht nicht direkt
hier nur einmal schmeißen
ich würde sagen zwei oder drei sachen
machen wir noch das hier schon der da
kommen wir noch mal hämisch seite
das ist heute morgen als angekommen
kultur wohin für sport
genau das können wir gebrauchen oder
leute kostenloser kulturbeutel kann man
sich in jedes badezimmer hängen man
braucht nur halten haken oder man kann
es auch in sein eigenes zimmer hängen
weise nicht habe ich wahrscheinlich
gesehen einfach direkt mitgenommen ist
geil also oder enthält ihr denn was aus
nein das habe ich mir jetzt anders
vorgestellt also aber abraten kann man
kann es wieder dran stecken also hätte
tatsächlich etwas aus perfekt also kann
ich empfehlen geistig gratis kann man
mitnehmen beisammen habe ich hier noch
liegen wir machen weiter ich sage euch
auch wirklich nur eines bestellt weil
das sind so sachen die werden die
datenmengen kostenlos angeboten und dann
habe ich heute ein einziges im warenkorb
gelegt und alle anderen die mir noch
angezeigt wurden ignoriert weil wer
braucht sowas schon also ich trage es eh
nicht da
das sind dann diese bänder die so am
strand und dann irgend welchen
urlaubszielen 55 euro verkauft werden
und zu guter letzt eine sache noch ihr
werdet euch jetzt sicherlich fragen was
willst du damit ich weiß es nicht es war
halt einfach kostenlos und das sind
alles gestellt kann man hier brutal oder
privater natur ja dass ein fahrrad hat
schon klar ich brauche das jetzt nicht
aber gratis ist schon gut
leute die haben ihr fahrrad handschuhe
und ich muss sagen die qualität hier
kommen eigentlich nur ganz gute qualität
und das für umsonst also da kann man
nicht mehr kann
das ist das letzte produkt mit dem wir
heute das video abschließen ich kann
euch aber versprechen ich bin ein
bisschen enttäuscht weil ich habe
gehofft okay wir haben hier drunter
jetzt schon sachen wo ich sage megageil
richtig gute idee die haben wir noch mal
alle sachen ich würde sagen am meisten
davon ist auf jeden fall diese leuchte
und dieser kulturbeutel und die
handschuhe ist am ende dass ihr war
wirklich kompletter müll was kein mensch
braucht schreibt mir super gerne
vorschläge in die kommentare für weitere
videos worauf er bock hat oder was mal
bestellen sollte
oder steht mir sagen wir bei instagram
zu 30 alex wie habe ich ja eben auch mal
kurz gezeigt und freut euch auf jeden
fall auf den zweiten und dritten part
hiervon oder eigentlich den dritten und
vierten part weil ich habe ja noch viel
mehr sagt
stellen und ich muss sagen ich bin ein
bisschen enttäuscht darüber dass wir
jetzt nichts dabei haben wo ich mich
wirklich darauf gefreut hab' weil wir
haben noch ein paar ruhig gadgets die
kostenlos waren die wirklich was können
und da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf
deswegen freue mich darauf das wird im
video blogger aktivieren kanal
abonnieren wir sehen uns morgen um 19
uhr wieder und wir gehen jetzt eine
frisch solar vox testen also das ist
eine rutschgefahr bank die ist hier drin
das ist eine power bank die funktioniert
mit licht also mit solarenergie und ob
das funktioniert wenn du rauskriegen ich
bin gespannt war sogar ein bisschen
teurer vorteil